we're on the bridge of the Geo Barons a
rescue ship patrolling the Mediterranean
on the lookout for migrant vessels in
distress
we've seen one a dot in the distance but
we're heading towards it
we're joining the rescue crews as they
prepare to Launch
there is an air of nervous tension so we
get it up we are just getting ready to
go on the ribs as we approach this
fishing boat which is reported to have
hundreds of people on it and is in
distress the Italian Coast Guard are
there radar Sergio Barons to carry out
the rescue
in the water we speed away using two
rescue boats they're known as ribs
the nearer we get the more people we can
see
but it's only when we get right next to
the boat that you can work out and help
every inch of space has been taken
and there are hundreds more people
crammed out of sight in the underbelly
of the boat
the challenge is to get them all off to
safety
so we've been Distributing life jackets
to all the people on board this boat now
the first person that's coming on board
it's not a general process there's no
time for introductions or niceties this
is about saving lives
many on board are dehydrated ill and
injured
and among them babies and young children
two ribs alternate Journeys back to the
Geo Barons with 30 or 40 passengers each
time
this old fishing boat set off from the
Libyan Port of tre Brook it could
probably have carried 30 or 40 people in
safety
instead there were 606 people who were
on board and they were all brought up
alive
getting people off the rescue boats and
onto the Geo Barons is hard work
boats have to be maneuvered precisely
and then the passengers transferred
sometimes with particular care
my mom when they arrived they're all
given food water and new clothes
it must be a bewildering experience many
of these people expect it to die
we meet handy and Assad they paint a
desperate picture little food no water
and suddenly abandoned by their own
Captain because the engines
became got broken and then he left he
decided to leave us like we're in the
middle of the sea wouldn't always north
east south
sky and the Sea nothing surrounding us
nothing Assad says rescue means a chance
to support the people he's left behind I
must fight and do my best to help my
family
that's why
make me
fight and sacrificed
the Geo balance is run by the charity
medicine San Frontier this the biggest
rescue the ships ever carried out
around most of Europe the number of
migrants is falling but in the
Mediterranean it's up 300 this year
Italy has declared a state of emergency
so as we head back to port in Italy the
geo-barrants isn't guaranteed a
particularly warm welcome the Italian
government says that ships like this are
a magnet that they are effectively giant
taxis for economic migrants
it's an accusation the charity denies if
we if yes people why they're leaving
their countries while they're putting
all their life and their families in one
bag facing borders facing a different
situation facing even that because
everyone knows that this route is quite
deadly you will easily understand that
there is no way to promote migration
this is a tale of desperate people huge
risks and the politics of migration
already this year at least a thousand
migrants have died in these Waters and
the summer approaches this route will
just get busier
Adam Parson Sky News on board the Geo
balance